un rendez vous attendu leur premier
depuis l'invasion russe en ukraine la
rencontre de leaders politiques alliées
en quête de soutiens mais ce siège bien
la chine dit vouloir assumer son rôle de
super puissance avec la russie pour
injecter de la stabilité dans un monde
où règne le chaos
la dîmière poutine 8 salue la position
qu'il estime juste et équilibrée
adoptées par la chine dans le conflit en
ukraine
en retour soutien à la politique de la
chine unique et dénonciation de la
visite de nancy pelosi à taïwan mois
dernier de la provocation américaine
selon lui les du leader autoritaire
vladimir poutine et si jean ping
promettent de solidifier l'organisation
de coopération de shanghai dont le
kazakhstan le pakistan et la haine sont
aussi membres l'iran et la turquie en
sont des partenaires l'organisme prend
des allures de front anti occidental
il s'agit du premier déplacement hors de
la chine depuis le début de la pandémie
de covè 19 pour si jean ping
son périple a commencé au kazakhstan
pays où il a lancé en 2013 après son
accession au pouvoir les nouvelles
routes de la soie projets
d'investissement dans les
infrastructures internationales
3 200 selon cet analyste c'est une façon
pour si jean ping d'annoncer la
continuité mais aussi le renouveau à un
mois du congrès du parti communiste
chinois qui devrait lui accorder un
troisième mandat historique si tu nous
vois pas tous hydro a suffi d'une
teinture la chine cherche à gagner
davantage en influence en asie centrale
selon lui profitant de l'affaiblissement
de la russie pourtant son allié si
gilles pays vladimir poutine se
retrouveront au prochain sommet du g20
au mois de novembre à bali en indonésie
ce face à face avec les leaders mondiaux
aura lieu au moment où les tensions
entre l'occident et les présidents
autoritaires chinois et russes sont
alors plus haut niveau il sait philippe
leblanc du canada taipei